[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
to day two
of cpap
2021. i'm your host
and we are live here at the wall of hell
to my right
your left is the beautiful angel
flying what's up angel
and in front of her down well down to
down there
it's a bishop mr brian smith
let me tell you something but y'all it's
it's bumping it it's bumping let me uh
have the extra thing so
uh y'all can see a lot of people walking
through
and they're gonna be stopping by to wave
and stuff like that so uh
oh jesus
merry christmas jesus
beautiful beautiful start uh this
morning uh ron desantis
angel was on stage ryan santa's game and
welcome everybody
to the cpap conference uh
ted cruz is out there uh
mike lee is not dennis morgan some say
he has the best of each other
from the ones i've watched yeah mike lee
knocked it out of the park
i'm not a huge mike lee fan yeah but
mike lee knocked it out of the park
uh unscripted for the most part
versus ron sanchez
you calling out to florida
talking points not here
well i yeah and i don't know if it's
devil's advocate or to
not not back up the sentence but
desantis
doesn't really control these uh regimes
if you will
it's just like dave county these regimes
that
keep their people on the lockdown
regardless whose government
if we had that problem down there
if they didn't come and they said oh
we got some circumstances
is
[Music]
yeah we were
enough spread
uh
so you know it's funny it's funny
because um
i've had my issues with the girls
and uh but they've been
low low opinion
because so many people have been
praising him
for different things i'm like i'm not
getting the real story of what's
happening down here right now
because last night we saw some
some issues you know
uh i don't think everything is open up
down here
oh god yeah last night
you know the cabbie
said no way we are earning really really
bad
um and the restaurant that we went into
everybody was messed up
uh he had to have a mask on to get in
obviously sit down
but it takes long and here's
don't have to do anything
is
all of these
it's hot
now it's one thing to have to wear a
mask inside and i know we've got a
pretty big crowd here at cpac
it is a large crowd but it's another
thing to have the employees and
it's frustrating for the employees and i
actually side with the employees and i
feel bad for you guys
because you want to keep your job you've
got to keep the job
paycheck pay the bills your manager says
walk the halls with a sign
saying
shouting back and forth it doesn't
need to go down that road to the folks
you know how i feel about the mask i've
been very very vocal
this past year i don't wear one of my
own hands
uh ryan did you wear one on the airplane
do a test on your audio
testing one two
brian is saying echoing
wayne
[Music]
let me contact our audio guy
it does sound funny yeah um
somebody said better wayne at least
well lisa says she can't hear anything
i felt like
can't hear angel riot echoes
is your mic open on here ryan won't ever
anymore
okay there we go all right fail fail
all right um and then with
angels
yeah brian
protected
do you hear yourself echoing on the app
the audio guy is coming over
how about this
how about this mic over here yeah
okay okay we have uh it says no sound
from angel we got that
however uh brian was just holding the
red
mic can you hear the red mic
use that mic to say something in there
yes we're trying to just
check out the sound
can you hear brian things are going okay
things are going okay here too
even though we can hear it here
no no hear her i can't hear her
it doesn't make any sense we're hearing
you and hear this
talking to your
oh wait uh check your
mic settings on your
it's supposed to be lex kind yeah but
that's not the mic
oh the mic yeah the mic should be good
right switch to that switch to that
other one
there's two lexicons there switch to the
other legs
no sound for me
okay
is it in the settings on the mac then no
can you guys hear me now
it defaulted to the lexicon but
sometimes when they show up
like that okay it's not actually going
to hit the lexicon confirming they can
hear me
they can hear you now yep okay
thank you everybody in the chat but does
brian still have
echo test test i am now testing the red
phone
the red microphone red microphone
thank you so much everyone in the chat
everybody's good to go now
and i i just gave the most brilliant
monologue
ever spoken it was huge it'll be
recorded for
my mind we got it on the hard drive
there were tears
it's on the hard drive it was
okay thank you so much thank you thank
you jay
you know echo for me clear on our clear
on uh weak
all right um these headphones are huge
these are meant
for giant humanoids
i can't i mean it's you gotta cover your
ears
i got um i got to speak this morning i
don't know if y'all got to see it
uh i was on with uh
lawrence b jones t.w shannon yeah
and uh we were talking about the mobs
and
what's happening here in america with
with that type of mentality
and i think i think
what happened or what we are trying to
get across and i know lawrence was
trying to do it
and we talked about on the show all the
time is that is
that you have some very bad actors on
both sides
that just aren't listening they aren't
listening to hear they're listening to
respond
and that way you don't have a
conversation you just have a good back
and forth
but i was trying to make the point
that a lot of the issues come from the
leadership
over the last decade everybody
down here on our level is looking at
everybody up there
for the last couple of decades and all
they're doing is fussing
yes so all so you can't expect that not
to filter down
into america
and then for them not to get pissed off
and kicked off
or know how to commute
pull through and communicate to make
things work
when government up there is not even
getting along
and the mob the mob factor
is interesting right because who is the
mob americans right now are angry
they're losing their jobs they don't
know how they're going to pay their
mortgage
and they're watching congress right
whose responsibility
responsibility by the way is to promote
the progress of science and they have
yet to bring doctors and biologists in
to get the real scoop on what this this
illness is about they're just listening
to king fauci one man oh i thought it
was to
to bake her back and forth from one
office to another
yes putting up flags and
you know for all intensive purposes
y'all y'all bigger enough that y'all
look like a bunch of children
yes i mean if you think that's funny
that's true did you put up
a flag uh lgbt trans
continental whatever the hell that means
and then for republican
oh i i i know you're solid uh second
amendment republican we know that you
carry we know all this
and now that's the fight that you're
taking come on man
yeah i mean if we didn't elect we didn't
elect these folks into office
to continue uh you know this this
activism
these signs these memes these jokes
these tag lines
do your job do your job we sent you to
dc
to get us back to work to get off our
backs
to roll taxes back to let us raise our
families
um but instead we're watching them
bicker amongst each other
call each other horrible names oh yeah
oh yeah
high school high school all over again
yes yeah i mean
and the cancer culture is
bully bullying on an adult level
yep you know yes it's called bullying in
high school and elementary school
but on our level it's called cancer
culture they don't like what you wear
they don't like what you say they don't
like how you look and then they're gonna
just
well you don't need to be on tv you
don't need to be here you don't need to
be there
it's like wait a minute but but then
again we need more people to say you
can't
you can cancel me right and
and that's what we need to do people
speak up like that but
and i don't want to beat this dead horse
but i'll be done with this aft
after i'm done with this uh you know
what what should they do what should she
do if somebody put a
if i was in office and i was elected
official and somebody put a
transgendered flag and i didn't even
know that there was one until yesterday
now i know that they now have a flag um
and i don't know where they stole those
colors from but the other one stole it
from the rainbow i digress
what should she have done so put that
that out there i would have actually
maybe make a phone call write a letter
do something i wouldn't have reacted
like you reacted with the uh what does
leah do leah always complains that the
aoc gets on the twitters and the the
instagrams and it starts ranting
and that's not what we need our
politicians to be doing is ranting and
raping
each other they need to be working yeah
but but but
but then again you know and and i don't
feel bad in saying this
no no up there can read they can't read
you don't know nothing about the
constitution it's not that they can't
they won't
you can walk up to maxine waters and ask
her about the 65th amendment right now
james o'keefe from project veritas
walking by she is going to
lie about what it's about there is no
65th amendment but
but she gonna stand there and argue with
you oh that's the amendment
that barack obama used and and that's
when he put the list together
of the people and it's a list like a
list that you ain't never seen before
we've got names and the people and the
places and things that we're going to do
when he could
yeah y'all remember that speech yeah
and the thing is is i mean we really do
have a country to save
and we're getting stuck in these sandbox
issues
we're constantly divided we're
constantly
picking these ridiculous battles and
they want us pitted against each other
because if we unite
we might find that we're all for freedom
nobody is saying they want grandma to
die nobody is saying
they don't want the children safe no one
is saying
any of that but what we're saying is i'm
an adult
i'm educated let me decide who the
experts are
let me determine what's best for me and
my family let me go to work
let me go to work that's what americans
want we're watching our enemies win
right now
right it's about opening this country
back up it's about people getting back
to work
um i know the stimulus packages is what
it looks like once its purpose is to
reward those states
that were incompetent in handling this
and getting their economies
back up and running and then to punish
those who did do the job
it's the government where welfare
rewarding those they
don't do what they're supposed to do
once again thank you liberals
yes yes we have actually i mean we've
seen from day one
and i think every single person saw this
coming the pandemic was going to be a
hundred percent
politicized and um
well there's dan yeah dan bongino is
right behind brian
and you're staying a crowd form
everybody everybody famous
damn hey wait appreciate you
ninja that's the whole name i haven't
heard in a minute
the news ninja how's
yeah let's turn the cameras off okay how
are you doing dee
yeah i don't exactly it's like it's so
close but it's not there
okay okay yeah it's like william
[Laughter]
thank you man we
everything is looking good on rumble
everything's looking good i'm looking at
the live streaming this morning
it looks good it really looks good solid
projects parallel economy
yeah i bet yeah yeah
that's scary yeah i mean you and i could
be next yep we got brands to protect
right exactly exactly exactly
but you know what one thing one thing
that i like about
is that contacting you behind the scenes
that's right i do have
his contact number they'll shut down
you know this just came out about you
man he was like that's how much i love
winning not me not me
chris the senior rumble yeah stream
he's yeah give me five ten guys you
think like the ringers
i said you gotta go to wayne think yep
thank you sir
right right we are good
there we go
the voice of reason every single day
that's all we do we just talk about the
voicemail
absolutely thank you thanks dan
appreciate you
oh man he dusted off the old school dan
bongino back in the day
in the beginning he was
always on wayne dupree was the ninja
yeah
yeah the news ninja and that's that's uh
that's what everybody knew him for i
mean he was on the circuit
before anybody else he was going live
and interviewing folks before anyone
else uh
donald trump sought him out to be
interviewed before he announced the
presidency
uh campaign yeah yeah i mean wait you
had people
we had means coming out of the woodwork
just to talk to you
um and you know you're not a flash in
the pan remember those days
i do remember those days and god bless
you for
for seeing it through i i had to take a
break and join them i needed i needed a
break so i joined the military
thank you angel thank you so much
i told angel uh
angel changed a lot of things before she
went to the military angel changed
a lot of my direction and she didn't
realize it
but she changed a lot of my direction uh
in the way that i should approach
different things
yes and you know uh i mean i
i thank her i don't thank her enough but
i thank her
for for doing it because
for me i just came to these um these
events
and when i got finished cpac i used to
go up to the room and you know just
wait what are you doing yeah
she was like wait a minute you just won
blogger a year
get your butt down here network
[Laughter]
what are you doing oh i'm gonna come to
my room no you're not oh
and here's the reason why here's the
reason why folks for all you out there
who have never met
wayne in person uh and i did not real my
dad is uh
engineer worked for the same company 42
years retired same time the same thing
just
a dry engineer that's just who he was i
had
no idea that he was a huge fan as he was
away debris
uh-huh so we we go out to dinner last
night and my dad
i've never in my entire life ever seen
him
dude he starts trying oh oh my god
afterwards my mom and dad my wife
everybody was like
wait did he have a good time together i
had a great time because
you know i just he's just like a regular
guy yeah i'm like
and that's the thing right you're saying
what most americans are thinking and
don't have the platform to say
and right now americans are feeling like
we're losing our voice we're being
overrun
and the wayne dupries of the world are
keeping us going
you know y'all keep me going
that's the thing y'all keep me going and
uh and before and before we get to our
first guest
i i want to say i sit back and i met a
lot of people
i sit back and i look up at a lot of
people
i don't have everybody as a co-host
on my show i know and a lot of people
are like oh we got to do we got to do
oh okay okay um yeah i get back to you
and stuff
i caught i called a i called brian
i called leah i called a couple of
people in
in the past i don't just put everybody
with me
that goes in line with a wise old guy
said me one time he said don't come at
me and he was he was promoting this to
everybody don't come to me
looking for me for something if our
paths cross
yes then our pants crossing it was meant
to be and i think that's what you're
trying to say exactly
exactly exactly and i mean
we are real we're going to be real
and the only way the only way to keep
doing podcasts
is to tell the truth so many people out
here they want clout
they want to be sue uh they want to be
praised
they want to be the the uh
the fruit of the week or the month
we don't care about that on this ship we
just want to be able to talk to you
and and motivate you or inform you
now does it stop there no go and
research
go on research come back now if we
messed up let us know
because we usually don't mess up that
much but no i don't remember the last
time i messed it up
and it's true it's true it's truth
rooted in charity right because we're
here to help each other
out right you know what i mean help each
other out don't use each other as a
stepping stone
it's so obvious it's so obvious when
people are trying to
to use you as a stepping stone i mean
you'll see him hanging around the wall
wait wait
wait he's like i'm on air
wait wait wait and nicole and the
purpose of this show at least
when wayne first started and when i
started way back in the day
and as well is to uh
say to save america in a sense of
educating
those that are looking for information
and there's a lot of people out there
starving that are just
desperate for the truth yeah and as we
said that truth resonates at a frequency
that you can hear
yes and this show has taken off but the
likes i've never been on the show before
because
of the truth that we speak here every
single day
and it's about getting the knowledge out
to you so that you can pass that on to
everybody else
coming to the stage right now is a
gentleman
that uh i admit uh that i was talking to
earlier
yep step up to the mic here we go he
has a book out called 37
days um the disenfranchisement of a
philadelphia poll worker
um his name is daryl brooks
uh he is he uh he started telling me
his story and i was like wait a minute
you gotta save some of that
so that everybody can hear you but um
he's a long time
little factor and um he found himself
caught up in a highly contested uh
situation and i'm gonna let girl take it
from here
you know what what's up daryl i am so
happy to be on the show for you
plenty of times and watched you and i'm
just so excited so i
thank you for allowing me to come on
mommy well
tell us tell us about this uh 37 days
we got 37 days from the bush score
election to 37 days of
president and so and we look and see
what's happening now at the convention
center
i was at the convention center i was a
philadelphia poll worker and i've been
basically uh new jersey activists
uh i'm working with the tea party
uh trump movement and uh
i moved to philly and i've seen all the
riots take place in the mag
like the maggot but the uh black lives
matter
and t for uh riots in philadelphia and
so i just said i have to participate
and and speak out about certain things
and i saw i've done a republican party
and uh in philadelphia and so they asked
me to be a poll worker
so i'm a poll worker and uh watcher and
i saw what was happening
um you know they are pushing us back you
can't
see uh what's happening uh they were
bringing ballots uh election workers
were bringing in ballots when they
shouldn't have
uh they had us against you know gates so
we couldn't see anything
and so when we went to court to get it
five five feet closer
they moved the whole operations back 100
feet
really yeah and so um and that's when
corey leondowski came
to me and he said daryl what did you see
in some other ones so we told them so we
had the press conference
we said we were planning on having a
press conference i said you know great
we'll be there
and that's when uh you know i met
giuliani and uh we had to approach
confidence on that day
and uh you know and that's history wow
now have you been a poll worker before
or was this different
people work in jersey so okay so um
those of us who just haven't had the
opportunity
to do that what was different about this
year versus
other years that you thought huh this
there's something going on here well the
gates
they had to get some so no one could uh
before as a co-working new jersey
footwork you can walk around
yes as they tell me about this observe
yes do not say anything they're not
you know just observe they didn't allow
us to do that
um and then also they had they
um they pushed us back and so
when they stopped that they stopped the
uh election
they said there was no more count then
we left
we get a call four o'clock in the
morning
said that counting ballots oh my gosh so
so we had to rush back uh
uh to the convention center and so as we
rushed back to convention center we were
like okay
this is wrong we can't do this so they
were counting ballots they were just
counting balance
they didn't check to see if individuals
lived here not uh they're just counting
pushing them through
this mission and you know president
trump that night was up by 700
000 uh votes next to you know he's down
so how did that happen in one day they
were pushing balance the fix was in
i think that was a big thing and who do
we blame the republican party
of pennsylvania and philadelphia for
allowing them
thank you they're the main reason and
they were telling me you know
you know they're part of the whole sort
of the rhino
you know they want to keep things the
same and
that's the big problem that the
republican party in
in pennsylvania had with president trump
yes uh they didn't want to challenge we
were out here challenging
you know it'll be okay you know it's
just an election no
it's not an election it's election for
the next generation
and for the future of america yes
and if the future of america is
is at harm you know we should do
something about it
amen and philadelphia is a city of
brotherly love
there was no brotherly love no there
were democrats upset with me
as a black man that's crazy for
supporting the president
and they were harassing me called the
security only three or four times
probably that i'm not a racist practice
and and follow me around
they were following me around to talk
about profiling right now
you know and uh and that's one of the
things that we were
highly upset uh but the fix was in
and it was terrible what they were doing
we were there for five
nights uh we saw so many and you know
where were these ballots coming from no
one knew
all we saw was that the the uh
the convention center the election board
philadelphia election board
bringing in ballots when they shouldn't
have done the ballot so there was no
way to police them how do you go to
police yourself if you
hate the republican party you definitely
hate donald trump you can do
everything you can to take him down
and so you know for the city of the
constitution
yeah you know the council there's no
real quick thank you when we talk about
philadelphia we're talking about when
went down
and and i'm from cincinnati so i'm kind
of like an outsider looking in i'm like
holy smoke i know it was bad in
cincinnati but it wasn't like wasn't
that bad
i'm looking at philadelphia and and in
my mind
i see a city void of any conservative
void of any gop void of any kind of
republican party leadership whatsoever
is that not true or is that true there
is no
i sat down with republicans in
philadelphia there is no really
republican leadership
they're individuals there were certain
individuals matt love
but the other ones they're just you know
they run falls they do not win there's
no really
um reason there's no republican party
that will sit down and challenge the
democrats message
messages yeah no messaging they are
afraid
uh they just you know just go along with
everything they're yeah boogieman yeah
and and it's sad uh you know and
something has to be done
and it was sad to see the republicans
just fall because
they allowed it they allowed uh the
democrats
and here's the thing and uh for everyone
listening
poll workers to me are just as important
as the military because they are
protecting
the sanctity of your right to vote
in a completely peaceful manner to speak
your voice
it is so important to
honor and respect these poll workers and
i mean everybody keeps saying the stolen
election is a narrative we need to stop
pushing
i when i was a political consultant just
like in philadelphia massachusetts the
republican party exists
just to be opposition they don't get to
do anything
and and the vote is stolen regularly the
vote is stolen and for people who don't
understand they say oh it's not that big
of a deal it doesn't make that much of a
difference
if that were true it wouldn't happen you
know
will smith's father voted he's been dead
for three to four exactly
you know yeah i mean really and so you
know my family in georgia said that
they all were just saying if you find a
turtle on a fence post
it just didn't get there by accident
someone had to put it there exactly you
know
someone in individuals they fixed this
election
uh you know and in the republican party
in wisconsin and other parts of the
extreme areas
they allowed it and the republican party
in georgia they allowed it to happen
they just you know using just a little
bit of common sense i know we know when
we look at
uh donald trump taking florida we know
donald trump taking ohio
larger than he took it uh back in 2016
donald trump taking
iowa the fact that he won those three
states
and a handful of others that go hand in
hand with that
and then you look at the counties across
the nation that he won versus
joe biden winning and then you see that
donald trump added
10 11 12 million more
voters for him that's the thing
and then we see joe biden uh
beating trump by more than
almost 10 million but but then beat
barack obama's historic 08 run by almost
20 million
yeah somebody's talking about somebody
told me
they were like well somebody tell me i
saw it on twitter
somebody was like okay you think you can
stop me
you
we got enough so in the book i talked
about lee cory leondowski
this is his book me corey lendowski uh
and
uh uh mayor giuliani were all in the
room and we're talking
so cool industry and giuliani goes in
the other room
i'm laying back i think like oh my god
oh my god this is happening
and i hear a voice in the background oh
upset you hear the rage the anger yeah
it's president trump's wow and he is
like he's going off he is going off on
giuliani and the tournament that
get something you know you know the
words he said you know
he was going out so then they come out
and then as the young lady comes in and
says they call the election
giuliani says who caught the election ap
called apb
doesn't pick a president and we're like
all right let's go so we go out there
you know i've done press conference
before
four or five but not on a massive level
like this
and i looked and you know then
giuliani says my friend daryl brooks and
i got nervous
and i would have ripped i was ready to
rip him but i was like
so caught up in the i was like wow you
know that wow
we're like oh my god this is this this
is really happening world
news right and um you know um
listen it was um but you know the heat
that i took from
democratic my friends in trenton new
jersey
the mayor the activists you know how
could you sit there with
uh giuliani how could you support the
president i have family members
you know they raided down in saint
mary's georgia you know they had a news
for me
i mean it truly is brave i mean people
need to think about this it truly is
brave to risk your
reputation to come forward and just
speak the truth
you saw what you saw what what happened
was completely underhanded
they stole the american people's voice
and you stood up and said something and
so that i applaud you sir because we
need more people like you and how how
has this affected your life since since
you know my girlfriend was you know she
had the baseball bat behind the door
when i walked into the house
she was shooting she got
think about that think about what people
are doing to get the truth out there
like they're risking everything to let
you know
what's happening and i've seen it
firsthand
mr brooks here has seen it firsthand
he's gone and
written the book to tell his story he
has gone everywhere he can to let people
know
hey mr brooks people keep saying 2022 is
going to be our year we just need to
vote again what do you say to that
awesome yes i mean 20 22 and 20 24.
yeah how do we how do we how do we
overcome this that yeah how do we
overcome what just went down we all
witnessed it
the curtain was pulled back trump pulled
the curtain back on the gop
pulled back the curtain on the dnc that
we knew they were wrong
but he pulled it back on how bad they
were and now we're seeing the aftermath
like the governor of
my uh mike dewine out of ohio uh was all
about
trump and but now he's all about trump
well you need to get out this is a real
election
how do we deal with these geo fears you
know listen i i think that
in 2024 uh in those swing states uh
no more mailing ballots how do you stop
that because if they're talking right
now
that's going to be anxiety there you
know listen you have to
organize we have to protests
you know marvel for king was my hero
non-violent civil disobedience
action so there are some of the things
that we have to get back into
involving listen lawsuits we have the
challenge and listen
we fight in this one school himself
video might not last
uh uh two more years right
uh you know 25th and also it's
it's uh i think that bite and the people
are going to see body for what he was is
a fake
funny he's been mediocre all his career
is nothing special about
biden he's ran what two or three other
times and lost
big comments about obama you know uh
lying about his uh speeches yeah
he said obama was articulate and clean
yeah
it's like like you're supposed to be uh
fluent in ebonics and dirty so i i think
and also i think uh
antifa and the rest of those the left
wing is gonna turn on body
definitely um one of the things that we
throw out there about that
is the left thinks that they can control
antique they think they they could as a
matter of fact
you can see what nance pelosi has said
many times oh well
we just have to talk to isis and you
know i don't give them a hug
give them a hug you know and understand
them and you and
and i'm paraphrasing but that but but
that's the way that she was going
when they're looking at antifa they're
like auntie fuzz for us you know
dinner we can talk to him that's a
frankenstein monster
frankenstein killed his creator
i was i was i was there in philadelphia
when he rioted in philadelphia
and t for black lives matter all the
different left-wing groups
burned up cars grocery stores all
businesses
bomb explosions there were people
blowing up atms
in philadelphia boom boom boom what's
that so
they can't control that they allow those
they allow individuals to rob and
village
but then they hate to so on the left
because
and if some individuals went up in the
capitol they wanted to see what's going
on right
you know i was you know they even said
my i was there i wasn't there
but somebody hacked my facebook page and
said let's go get
you know i'm looking for bonnie come on
watson and i was on the bus with 56
people
and then they got up you know and there
was all uh you know listen
people are dissatisfied you know these
groups you know
listen the president has done a great
thing people feel that
uh election was stolen it was stolen and
the left
has done a a hell of a thing uh
to this country and to what people are
saying
uh you know we talked about this thing
called i've talked about i think
cultural marxism
look on netflix we're seeing in tv shows
movies
are changing what these kids believe in
yeah thinking you don't have kids going
to church anymore you don't have kids
with values yeah in schools you have
young people
whether in the city suburb black or
white uh
graduating from 12th grade with third
fourth grade reading yeah
functionally illiterate yeah what types
of when amazon get automated and all
these other stores
what type of jobs are these kids gonna
have right just boxes just moving them
and upset moving it moving them or
stealing them right yeah
and we talk about this all the time but
something that my pastor said
is that there were some numbers he was
looking at and our generation gen x
at least we we knew about church and we
were kind of raised the majority of us
were raised in church
yeah we ran away from it in our 20s and
our 30s and just kind of got crazy but
at least we had something to fry right
we had more guard rails that we knew
were in place we just
jumped them and now that we then we got
straight like you know what those moral
guard variables are there for a reason
these kids nowadays there is no
foundation of moral guard rails
my grandmother down in saint mary's
georgia god bless the mama grayson
took me to church five days a
on a week on a sunday i might have went
to church two
twice or three times in the conference
united members come
home the preacher get the best of the
fried chicken
yeah the creature get the best of the
and we're sitting down there and i'm
eating you know and that's what is in
the african american media
in the south fried chicken every sunday
morning every sunday
each supper or eat dinner and then we go
back to a church somewhere in the woods
come back
yeah that's fine michael our family was
shrimpers myself
my mom would put on dinner before we
went to church put on low heat
low heat because she knew we weren't
coming back for about four or five hours
a long journey it could be a long time
by the time he came back the whole house
is smelling like smothered chicken
chicken yeah yeah but i always tell
people
i we went to church ten days out of
seven yeah
you know i still love listening to
mahalia
yes i still love oh yeah yeah come on i
still
all those and and it's so it's
it's peaceful because my grandmother she
would have me hell yeah jackson
shirley caesar and when electric's on
the lightning storm happens
raining sitting on the porch reading
bible tell the stories i love that
those were the things that you know kept
us involved and kids today don't have
that no
they don't have a mama grace no no
there's moral guard rails that they just
don't have
yeah and i talk about it in my book and
you know i talk about grandfather
my actually in politics where i was 10
years old
my cousin uh artie jones and and saint
mary's georgia camden county ran for
county county commissioner
he had me holding up some and you know
speaking out
you know i mean holding the political
side he was a democrat
i love him he pushed me towards that you
know coming back to train
in the summer time well i lived in trent
with
saint mary's georgia in the summertime
came back at the library
they said the library is closing mr
damiri god bless him he said would you
like to speak at city hall
so i'm 9 10 years old
at city hall asking why do you have to
close the city library
and your political theory yeah so i you
know i've been in politics and social
activism
radio and i was with the southern
christian leadership conference
i did the 40th anniversary of the
assembly montgomery to march
and so you know having meetings like
reverend al sampson doctors were not up
yet
uh yeah that's harry belafonte
all those guys beveled all them that
marched with dr king yeah
reverend james orange they called love
the leader
sitting with these guys talking about
what was the difference now you know
things that martin king did in the
states reverend shuttlesworth the great
things that these guys did in the 60s
you know they were my inspiration huh
well look
there i like um love to have you come
back on
a regular show you the man okay
and um we want to get it out uh a whole
lot further than past cpap too
so and uh how can people find you on
social media
so you can find this book on amazon
amazon 37 days
all the co-writers steve martino he's
here with me
it's amazing that books out now
you know and so yeah it was one of the
most interesting things in getting it
across it's uh
are you on social media yes uh facebook
uh
daryl m brooks daryl m brooks on
facebook yeah
and i'm using facebook i had the on fire
show
and uh which i got the name on fire show
i tell the story about glenn beck
you know he was talking about doing the
uh
problem what was that thing and uh uh
know i sleep my mind but he's saying the
world was on fire oh yeah
oh that was during the uh obama term
when they were
all over saudi arabia all the egypt and
the whole
movement the ones were there oh the on
fire show so i
you know on fire show i got the name
from that uh
so it's uh it's been exciting and you
know this book
you know talks about me growing up the
ins and outs the you know
uh the justice system i you know about
the saving a guy life
uh friend of mine i didn't know a guy
just walked on and saved his life
he gave him cpr and he died 16 days
later mr mcnamara
but he's an irish guy and then his
family uh his wife and two sons were
like
brothers wow that's amazing
and uh you know just for inner city guy
and in that suburb in a totally
different area
and we became best friends and she's
like a [ __ ] wow
all right that's amazing all right man
daryl
brooks find him on facebook
thank you thank you appreciate it 37
days on amazon
37 days on amazon uh the
disenfranchisement
of a philadelphia poll worker let me get
this book up here real quick
to you 37 days we're going to have him
underway the pre-show right out uh
a little bit after cpac but we're gonna
have him like if you want to um
take questions well if you want to call
up the questions and stuff
we get that done too all right um
with that said we are through our first
hour
i can't see it oh yeah he's just putting
it up daryl um
on facebook we are through our
d-a-r-y-l d-a-r-y-l-m
brooks i am so glad to hear
from these poll workers thank you so
much sir i i added you as a friend
we friends
that's awesome okay thank you this is
what we're gonna do ladies and gentlemen
we're gonna
take a quick break take a three-minute
break
from uh for anybody that needs to go to
the bathroom we're gonna be right
back so make sure you don't even turn it
off
don't leave just go to the bathroom and
come back like it's old school
television
and look we're gonna be here for the
next couple hours relax
okay as my kid said to me last night in
the hotel room dad pause it
i can't pause nothing
[Laughter]
uh but no queen dupree
angel fleming brian smith right here at
cpac
2021 don't go nowhere we promise
we promise we got some more people that
we want to interview in just a few
minutes
so uh yeah there's any part and chat
before we go
that's it thank you yeah all right see
you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
so
well
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
i'd love to hear that good good good all
right here we go
a little bit more than three minutes i
know wasn't it
everyone's like where are they in the
chat they're like fitting
all right yeah that was more like 15 but
we did have technical
difficulties yes we did i don't know how
we got logged out but yeah
yeah it's hey ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the wiener show we are
live here at cpac 2021 that's right
we are way into the year we're supposed
to be having flying cars
yeah and living off of uh grass
outside some people do hold on
somebody sent me the cartoon uh the
barbarian
cartoon and it says at the very
beginning of the show it says
in 2014 as the
the comet comes through the earth and i
remember that person yes
that was my favorite cartoon um
yeah i mean um 1990 says in 1994
as a comet comes through earth and and
destroys earth
drips strips the atmosphere and stuff in
right supposed to have robot butlers too
i thought oh yeah i mean well roomba
counts i guess you got the little
things that get stuck mess up
mess up those little animals and stuff
you know that a little robot
vacuum cleaner yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so that counts that's a robot
butler that's that's
the best we could do
hey what show is this this is a rain
freak
oh okay i'll just check in yeah
that's angel ladies and gentlemen andrew
fleming
co-host here yeah 2021.
and also mr brian smith bishop yeah yeah
i've now switched to water i was
wondering
these two were passing i don't know what
back and forth that's the last segment
that's look up no no that's that's a one
this is this is how these two these two
party is
starbucks double shot they split one
because they're crazy
it's so wild it's not code that does
seem really wild in the age of coping
they're like ooh sharing and like
pouring it together and they're like no
you got too much this is all happening
during our last segment you got too much
and he's pouring into his cup and he's
what is going on here i mean i feel like
a beer put on blood
i'm just trying to hook a brother up
i mean in vegas
[Laughter]
yeah they were fighting over how much he
got in the car he gave me that hold up
hold on
he saw that i had one yes i was prepared
i saw him and i filled my cup up and he
gave me the stink and he kept filling up
the cup
he saw me look at him and he kept
filling up the cup
and here's some professionalism you had
no idea this was happening the entire
time we were interviewing daryl brooks
that's true you had no clue this was
happening
that's professionalism at his best i
just rest across
and i said and i'm watching them i'm
watching them go back and forth like no
no no
too much a little bit more the only
reason why it's like this because i
tried to squeeze the rest of it out
oh my god all right all right so ladies
and gentlemen we have
a young lady that is going to join us in
just a few seconds her name is cassandra
spencer
she is an author a whistleblower and a
journalist
she has a book coming out
in march and the probably the
uh first couple weeks in march but um
it's called impact
and i asked her to join the show you can
follow her she even got tick-tock
uh what you know about the tic-tocs she
got that that's actually where i
initially went viral was on tick-tock
tick-tock i don't even take any time i
you know i i
i watch the ticking time
i had a bunch of teenagers trying to
bully me about the size of my forehead
that was when i knew i had made it on
top
nobody can nobody was a crap a teenagers
think ever
they don't know that who are you people
you're nothing
you don't mean anything oh good guys um
um cassandra tell us about impact
coming out in march 9th
yes so impact comes out march 9th what
it is is it's actually my memoir
where i tell my story about um i was
actually the original project veritas
tech whistleblower so i blew the whistle
on facebook
i used to be a contractor there back in
2017 and 2018.
uh back when they at least tried to hide
the censorship
they tried to be sneaky about it back
then um
so anyway i was a contractor there i
ended up leaking documents to project
veritas ended up losing my job ended up
losing
everything i mean even down to it
becoming a family court issue and losing
my daughter
what yeah i'm not even joking uh it
became
just this crazy issue in my life where i
lost everything i had even though i was
a single mom who had put themselves
through college on an rotc scholarship
when i was younger
i had to go on food stamps for a few
weeks oh my gosh because i lost
everything now after i blew the whistle
on facebook and all that happened
i actually ended up going on to work for
project veritas as an undercover
journalist
okay where i went undercover into
big tech companies like google i got to
help tell a lot of the other
whistleblowers stories as an undercover
journalist
as well as going into political
campaigns like um beta o'rourke's
senate campaign and uh bernie sanders
primary
presidential campaign that beetho senate
campaign
that was quite amazing how he was able
to raise so much money in the state of
california
oh yeah yeah it was funny his staffers
they would literally call him daddy vado
[Applause]
and i'm sure you go into this in your
book so i won't have you spill the tea
too much
but um what did you see at facebook that
you thought was so appalling you needed
to come forward and
make it known to the public so i
actually didn't
go into facebook believe it or not
intending to blow the whistle on
anything
right it's just a job everybody has a
job right yeah i actually thought like i
was like okay this is a cool job it
wasn't easy i was an intellectual
property analyst so i
dealt with like you know people
illegally streaming disney movies and
game of thrones episodes
but all of a sudden occasionally i would
get like a copyright ticket from
you know political personalities and
including conservatives
and i started noticing odd notes on the
accounts of the conservative pages
and they never appeared on the liberal
pages only on the conservative pages
and so you know you see it once or twice
you kind of ignore it you're like okay
that's kind of weird whatever
but then you keep seeing it over and
over and over again and you're like this
is clearly a pack
right what kind of notes um so the
specific code said
ia live action dboost live distribution
d boost i don't like that word and
that's what people were wondering about
like people were very suspicious about
that
right and people were suspicious about
it and i i saw the notes and i could see
who the engineer who wrote the code was
you know because it was in the account
notes section where like if i had
copyright stricken someone's account
it would say you know cassandra spencer
you know copyright strike
right and so i kept seeing this pop up
and then of course i went down the
rabbit hole and started finding all
these other documents that were on
you know internal wikis that i had
access to um
you know talking about plans for
censorship and like this is 2017 and
so it wasn't nearly as blatant as it is
now i mean now they've come full out of
the closet
when we first started this show last
year uh right at
the start of kovid we were getting huge
numbers 100 200 300 500 000
all the way up until about what was it
like the first week of october
then we it was a copyright strike
it was a copyright strike of camilla
kamala harris where the article written
said that
quoted camilla harrison i believe the
women
that accused joe biden and then she said
that right
so that was literally facebook said no
she meant kicking out
so when you talk about dboost from that
moment forward from 100 200 500 000
views
on a daily right
3 500. yeah exactly 10 000.
that's what this code was and you could
see where the code was enacted on um i
saw it on mike cernovich's page i saw it
on stephen crowder's page i saw it on
the daily callers page
and so these weren't like you know
fringy weird people
by any means and this wasn't this also
wasn't some troll engineer just doing
his own
no this was policy it was some kind of
protocol right because then we found
policy documents that kind of supported
you know all these plans because that
was when i went down the rabbit hole i
was like what's going on here
you know out of curiosity so i had you
know started finding all this
information and then
james o'keefe had tweeted one time like
if you're in the inside of these
companies you know reach out to the skip
line
uh like veritas tips at protonmail.com
so i ended up reaching out to the tip
line
and kind of just the rest is history wow
now first of all thank you okay um
because
cpac's theme unironically this year is
hashtag uncanceled
and we've had a few people brave
americans that have come forward risked
everything
and we're going to talk about that in a
second risked everything to just get the
truth out to the american people
and those out there who keep saying like
it can't be that big of a deal it can't
be that big of a deal there's a reason
why people are coming forward
there's a reason why they're saying it
you know so if you could cassandra just
speak to a little bit what you've
experienced
as a whistleblower what you faced
to just let people know the truth um
some of the hardships that you faced
and things like that oh yeah well of
course the immediate hardship was is i
knew that as i was going through and
gathering this information i knew that
losing my job was a possibility
yeah of course i didn't know what was
going to happen when they actually did
it
so i go into work one day you know my
manager says hey
we got to talk to you in the conference
room you know i'm like okay
i hate it when
you still got a couple hours left ain't
nobody looking
like just walking out the front
like um can i can i speak to you for a
minute oh yeah no no that's exactly how
it was it was like
yeah can we just talk to you for a
little bit and then you see all the
gophers
[Laughter]
she goes she goes
and usually the reason that people would
get fired is it's like you know people
would
go and like try to look at like an
ex-boyfriend's yeah
violation of privacy so i'm assuming
that's what my co-workers thought i had
done
something you know pretty routine and so
i get called in this room they shut the
door
you know and it clicks behind me oh no
and
uh hopefully your boss isn't matt lauer
but anyways go ahead
sorry i had to throw that out there they
they sit down and they said that the
client um
wanted me to be terminated immediately
because he was a contractor right yeah
yeah
even though i was at the facebook
facility in austin texas
and i can i ask i said uh well
can i ask why i'm being let go and they
said um
they won't tell us we don't know so they
just fire people because
because the prime because they just tell
you to they can fire whoever they want
whenever i mean it's not will employment
so technically they can't
it was very sketchy when you're a
contractor and i was a contractor
for a huge shipping company and
when they would tell me that one of the
employees
they they don't like the attitude and i
as the contractor needed to tell him to
go i had to find my head immediately i
needed no questions
it was part of the contract yeah exactly
and so that was fine but then what
happened
is they said um and facebook security
would like to see your cell phone
oh i don't know about that yeah mind you
this is a personal
cell phone this is not facebook property
i don't know if that's it
i don't think that's legal um no it is
not they can't do that
and so i had nothing of any interest on
my personal cell phone so i went and
she's smart yeah and i asked i said well
if i let you see my cell phone do i get
to keep my job
and they're like no it rocks
idiots but why am i gonna let you see my
phone
and so we end up in this circular
argument where they're like facebook
security
is like insisting that they need to see
your personal cell phone
and i'm like no i'm not going to give
you my cell phone so we go back and
forth for two
hours i am stuck in this conference room
two
hours and finally i'm like this
conversation is clearly not going
anywhere
so can i just leave yeah that's a really
dramatic firing oh yeah go on for a long
time
and then this was their response this is
the kicker well
um legally we can't detain you i know of
course not yeah
bye-bye obviously yeah
legally but if it was legal
i told a boss one time that was firing
me that did something similar to that i
looked there and said
i don't work for you no more yeah think
about it like
when when you're dismissing somebody
somebody from employment
it's uh you're fired goodbye it's not a
two-hour
interrogation i mean facebook has a
legal team
obviously right right um so why would
they waste but they probably were hoping
that you were scared and you would just
turn over whatever you have
yeah and that's i mean unbelievable so
anyway go on so you get fired from
facebook yeah so i get fired
um you know obviously i can't even go to
my desk to clear out my belongings
anything
two weeks later they still refuse to
return like just basic stuff like you
know pictures of my kids and like you
know
um what headphones to me and so i have
to threaten to call the austin police
department on facebook to get my
belongings
back
yeah this is i cannot make this she
called the police on facebook
i had to threaten to i ended up not they
finally sent some from the contract
company to give me my stuff back at a
starbucks
oh my gosh this is how petty liberals
are they really are this friggin petty
in real life where they just it was just
ridiculous i was like i just want my
stuff
like i'm not asking for anything weird
and so
uh that was kind of the thing and so you
know i get fired i'm walking out to
my car in the parking garage and i call
my parents you know first call i make
and the first thing my dad asks me is
because he knew what was going on a
little bit
he says was it worth it and
immediately i didn't even think about it
i said yes
because i knew that what i saw and the
things that i had uncovered
were egregious enough to where the
public had a right to know what was
going on
with this company that's collecting your
information they're collecting people's
money
and then they're doing all the stuff to
censor them yeah and a lot of these
pages
pay to be promoted and they're being
de-boosted
um yeah you know you know um
one thing i noticed and since you worked
there you might have a little insight
you might not but
i noticed that a lot of people were
getting removed from facebook
but the one constant story that they
were given was
i spent such an exception such
creating my page on facebook and now
they're kicking me out
it's but like for me i'm still on there
they've killed everything of people
seeing me
but i don't spend any money on it but it
seemed like
some people i yeah spent 300 big money
to boost their promotions yeah yeah and
they kicked me off
and i started noticing a pattern it
seemed like the more people
spent the more people were getting
kicked off i'm like well that's just a
waste yeah because if you have that kind
of money to spend you're that kind of
threat
and i saw that early on early on back
2015 2016 i was like well maybe okay so
i was like twenty dollars here thirty
dollars there for the show and i was
like
what that crap yeah yeah this is the
enemy and i'm gonna get and i just i
stopped doing
it yeah i know i got the d monetization
throttling so now big tech has their
first enemy
their first known enemy which is you
casandra you're the first one
right you're you're the judas to
zuckerberg right now
okay so what does that look like you're
walking out of facebook
you finally get your your earphones in
the picture your daughter back
but then what then what are you
panicking oh crap
yeah well are there threats no there
weren't any threats or things like that
my roommate and i we noticed in like odd
vehicles in our neighborhood but nothing
that we could confirm
you know i was like he's got enough
money to do things just to mess with you
did you keep a facebook account you know
i actually
did i deactivated for a while but then
um i'm
on the platform still almost as an act
of defiance okay because it's like
i dare you to kick me off this platform
right
and so um
my goodness boys sorry right there um
she's at her house she's seeing weird
cars drive by
well and my roommate and i we're like
panicking about like
you know how are we going to pay the
rent next month yeah and so
that was what was really crazy is it
just became this kind of snowball effect
of things happening
now mind you during this time i had sent
this information over to project veritas
and you know they're
corroborating everything and you know
doing their due diligence on it because
i could be some crazy lady right of
course
that never happened i'm sure that there
are so many tips that go
to project veritas just to make them
chase their tails right so they have to
vet everything
they have to be above board for every
little thing they do well and yeah
that's why they're you know
in lawsuits because they are very
careful about what they do
absolutely and so we actually premiered
my insider story at cpac in 2019
okay um i was ins they had my picture up
on the big screen like in silhouette
i was sitting like somewhere
surreptitiously in the audience
but um what happened was i then went on
to work undercover for them
good um i had a journalism background as
a army public affairs officer
nice and so it you know it seemed like i
was like okay well
you find yourself uh without a job now
you might as well do this when life
closes the door god opens a window right
and then i got to help tell the stories
of other whistleblowers
good over time and so that was actually
probably one of the most rewarding
things i did
um including one of the stories that i
did was going undercover with google
wow there was a google executive named
jen gennady
who talked about how they were training
their algorithms to
quote prevent the next trump situation
whoa
this is back in 2019 oh my god
and that ended up being cited on the
floor of the house the senate by the
president yes
so uh yeah that was that was me thank
you
for your service these are unsung heroes
yeah these are people willing to put
their life on literally
your life on the line i mean nobody goes
up against silicon valley
you know walking away on skate and like
i just love what you guys are doing over
at project veritas
i'm so glad that you landed in this
position it really feels like god wanted
you there
um yeah so so proud of what you're doing
keep it up
well and it's been crazy because uh my i
left project veritas at the beginning of
2020 my identity had never
been been public up until that point at
some point last summer my identity was
leaked to the media
and all of a sudden i wake up and there
are people outside my house
i had a tinder date had this picture
taken outside my house that's great
him down on twitter and messaged him
saying
we know you know cassandra spencer
please reach out to us
i i i kid you not like i have the photos
that they took of him and i
walking outside of my house do you know
who it was um it was
people from the new republic is the
publication
um yeah it's like a jezebel type uh
petty stuff for those of you out there
listening right now to her story
i just want to say that thank you
for going through the fire whether you
wanted to or not
it came to you it was tough uh
looking back now hindsight 50 50 you've
got an
incredible story to tell um
and and i'm just going to assume because
it's happened to me too when you look
back
if you could have suffered more properly
being well i know this will end i know
this will pass
i know god's got a plan for my future
okay what does this mean what does this
mean
and you get through that and in the end
you look like wow
maybe i could have suffered without
being so angry at all those people
and maybe take myself a little bit and
not take the poison pill hoping they die
but you know so for those of you out
there going through it right now
hang in there it won't last you can make
this
make it through this you'll come out the
other end and if again i said earlier in
the show if we're supposed to meet we'll
meet we'll meet on the street we'll meet
dm wherever we'll get you to help you
get your story out james
i promoted jane since i've known him for
the last five six seven years phenomenal
uh job they've been doing over there
project veritas
and again like i said what eight no on
law suits i mean how you do that
when you're right you're just right yeah
yeah and like i said uh
doing the right thing sometimes it's not
the easy thing
but you will never regret it because not
a day goes by that i ever regret my
decision of whatever right you never
regret the right thing no no no never
right but if you were still working at
facebook today and never had done that
yeah i mean you'd have been miserable
you better watch you would have watched
us all being under attack on facebook
knowing full well what was happening and
then and this is you know to me
an inspiration to everybody uh that has
been suffering under
2020 in 2021 a lot of medical
uh professionals afraid to come forward
afraid to do the right thing and say the
right thing because they're afraid of
losing their job but look what happened
to
cassandra you know what i mean a phoenix
rose from the ashes look at what she's
doing now
you know face hardship but she's a
badass you have to be proud
oh i am very proud and i'm working on
some things we haven't quite
officially announced yet um but we're
gonna
keep fighting especially there in the
state of texas
did you want to announce something here
we're considering a run for office
we are considering you know if and when
you know put the feelers out there and
you know see
see if that works out if and when please
by all means wait come back
yeah yeah we got it obviously yeah yeah
i mean all right i just said
if we're on the first name oh yeah
she's an army girl amongst a lot of air
force people right now
we still family we still family
grooming our green at our blue party
it's fine except the time i spent in
aberdeen proving grounds baltimore
maryland i i'm
still in therapy
for forgiveness for for them putting an
air force member on that proving ground
sorry oh i know you guys get uh i think
you get some kind of like
hazard pay yeah when you have to stay in
one of our hotels yes yes yeah
it's not up to your standards yeah no
yeah we do you know
y'all kind of act up a little bit
you know those tables through the window
oh my god
that's not normal
if i was normal i probably would have
been willing to lose my job i know
i don't know that goes exactly with
you know love you for it love you
foreign right
you know because me and him would have
been a child but you know you you know
you and look we need something done and
we're going to do
it yeah that's a good sign they're
having pizza today yeah
yeah yeah who's teddy where are you
going oh
i gotta expose them okay good luck with
that
we see the job i'll see you about a
dessert
carousel you know the air force does
have one though yeah we do
oh i was told no no you don't need that
don't touch that
saucer it's not allowed to be touched my
buddy my buddy was a sailor and he was
on an air force base for the first time
he's like y'all have
soft serve in your chow hall and i was
like yeah he's like i just got kicked
out of there he was like under it
drinking from it like it was a tap just
you know brain freeze and everything and
like oh my gosh this is why
we get hazard pay when we go on you guys
basically so this is
this inside ball game y'all this is this
is what military members do when they're
all
well look cassandra we want to have you
well we're going to have you back
and uh i'm sure we can open up the phone
line
so people can ask you some questions oh
yeah more than happy too
yeah um how can people i mean i've been
tweeting out
a lot of stuff that you've been saying
anyway but how can people find you on
social media right now
um twitter is cassandra spencer minus
the e in my last name because yeah i
found that it's too long
my name was really one letter too long
those character limits are legit yeah
yeah that was the only way i could fit
my name and
um or cassandra spencer tx on tick tock
and then impact is available uh the
kindle pre-orders are currently
available on amazon
the but when the book comes out march
9th it will be available on
kindle paperback and hardcover that's so
there you go there you go
you got your vanna white behind you
holding the
poster can't wait i can't wait for that
to come out that's going to be amazing
can't wait look at sandra you've been an
inspiration
thank you so much this is amazing i made
it all right i got you on the tiki talks
take any time my goodness
the tick tock i can't believe it she's
going to take any time
yeah she's got she's got a whole lot of
followers like a hundred
thirty thirty thousand right that oh
that's you right
yeah you're working she said she went
viral yeah yeah
yeah that's yeah that's hard work when
you get once you get kicked
once you you get kicked out with the
trumpster and everybody else and they
take you out on the same day on the
on the twitter you gotta find somewhere
else i found it kinda took down
really thank you thank you cassandra
we'll be talking to you again soon this
is amazing
so great all right ladies and gentlemen
so many great people coming out today
and talking to us about their brave
stories
you know they were risking it all and
that's what i like these patriots are
willing to step
up and speak the truth she did she did
facebook and she did google
yeah yeah yeah that's called badass
yeah she brought that [ __ ] to congress
can i say that on the air sorry
what'd you say again
she brought that ish to congress oh
there you go
yeah that's what we need more of
honestly today ladies and gentlemen we
good wayne's calling somebody over
because he has snacks
ladies and gentlemen we in florida but
this is a government this is the real
governor of florida right here
this is the real governor of florida
this this this young man uh is going to
be running
for office real soon real soon
i heard it here first again
he's gonna be running for office and i'm
gonna come down here and i'm gonna help
him out to you
but javier uh is
is uh has been part of the conservative
bloc well
using the word blog is to manager for
him
he i hate the red block because
the man is so amazing there are no words
yeah you keep going online i'm modest
too
one of your many amazing qualities is
modesty i love that
we are in your negative wood yes uh did
you ever think cpac was gonna be down
here
in your negative woods i never thought i
never i just i always figured it makes
sense being
tech and i'm sorry in dc because of all
the politicians
easier for them because of the swamp
right yeah right well it's easier
usually they've had it over the years
where they could just vote and then
shoot right over or shoot over before
they vote right it was easy they just
went home uh and it ended on saturday
exactly thank you and now we miss out on
sunday because we were caught up into an
ending on saturday church yeah
traditionally yeah yeah me too i used to
go to church
i used to go to church
in the comfort of my own home because i
told people
if you are coming on sunday to watch
trump you better pack a lunch
you better have you better have a lunch
box
a little mobile porter party because
they was taking polls on fox and friends
this morning
on how long was trump's speech going to
be 45 an hour two hours
three hours more i was like oh really
hey he's going he's going two and a half
he he's got something to say
he's the only reason why there's a
sunday he's the only reason why there's
a sign
he wouldn't draw actually i was in
mar-a-lago two nights ago
when i when after laura loomer announced
they invited me over
and i don't know if you've ever been
there it's very decadent very gaudy
never been there yeah it's all like it's
all out as soon as
i pull into the valet don jr
right over here and then we walk in i'm
thinking i only see
i only counted six secret service guys
i'm looking around
thinking that's what it is they got eyes
everywhere i'm thinking
this this glass has got some kind of
camera or this guy who's carving
who's fishing he's dishing out these
balls and he's actually you know
the meatball guy is secret service
because i mean michael dell was there
with the pillow guy
yeah i hit him up for a pillow of course
hey hey we said yeah he said it was
wayne it was in the mail yeah okay
so it was a interesting experience so
you said that you talked to
laura lara is going to run again yeah
she now she's running but
this time is she's running against lois
frankel but because florida is
redistributing all over the country
the florida gate is going to gain two to
three seats at least
good good so it could change the
district so she said regardless of what
happened she
reserves the right to run in another
congressional district it doesn't
necessarily happen at 21.
okay so well how about that you got to i
know
yeah you know i get that all the time i
walk into a public supermarket
or any restaurant they'll say they
either applaud or they throw an apron at
me
there's the governor get to work they
say amigo get to work
so look um a lot of
now i did i talked to
javier behind the scenes and stuff like
that so
uh what do you how important is local
politics
well i mean that's the farm team for
most most uh political parties
you know how did senator rubio start he
was a podunk
city commissioner of the city of west
miami which i think has 10 people in the
population
okay maybe more maybe 10 maybe 15. but
so he started from there he catapulted
to
speaker of the house or legislative
speaker of the house now he's
uh i don't know what he's doing what do
you what are you doing now yeah i think
so
yeah who knows what he's doing honestly
yeah
he's throwing pillows at the wall at the
tv whenever his dolphins lose
he just trust me soft spot that's a
dolphin loss
well i i mean i i know i know um
i know we tell people that local
politics is in sexy
uh you know you don't get all the big
perks that you get in washington dc but
you know i i totally agree with you
you know it's very important it's very
important
that's where you cut your teeth if you
will there was a young lady that
were either interviewed today or maybe
tomorrow that talked about running
for lieutenant governor or whatever
she's run for and i asked her flat out i
said
uh what if you you know just be honest
what have you done before what have you
ran for before
and she went through a list of things
that she ran before
which actually gave me more confidence
you know what this could be a real solid
interview just to even talk to you
it just keeps in point look at matt
gates he just spoke
yeah matt gates was a representative
congressional seat opened up he ran for
congress now he's considered running for
a g
of florida really yeah and why is that
because
it's a it's a better setup to go to
ascend to governor and into president
trump well you have to consider the 10th
amendment too
because the federal government is
nothing without the states and a strong
state
government is what will keep the federal
government from its overreach or at
least that's how it's
supposed to work but if you if you send
every rock star to washington dc
then you have nobody at home i mean look
at south dakota donald trump
tried to tap christine and she was like
no my people need me here and you have
to applaud that you have to applaud
people that will stand up for their
states and local communities
you can't just like you know hop skip
and jump all the way up to the top when
the states actually need some defense
you see some of the worst atrocities
against the economy
were were from liberal-run cities and
counties
that had nobody to stand up to them so i
think local politics is extremely
important that's where you earn your
stripes
the top right yeah yeah there's there's
a lot of like i have in broward county
florida which is
the second most liberal popular city
county in the whole country
and the state is next to miami i love it
you know why because there's i mean i i
love bumping i was with the debbie
wasserman
but let me just tell you for me because
i cover florida national politics
i'm in there and i'm in the mix with
debbie wass michelle's debbie macasso
powell who lost i guess
we had all the big a lot of big liberal
names even charlie crest who should be
republican they're in florida so
i have you know i have them i live very
close to them so i can actually
go to events so it's it kind of plays to
what we want to know
we do but i mean it's fun i mean i i get
along with a great debut
you know loves to hate me so it's all
good well that's what the left does they
love to hate anyway oh yeah
at least i get a hug and a kiss out of
me
don't do it don't go there oh no no no
you know what she's good people as a
matter of fact she um she uh
gave me hell a couple of during the riot
and i was in dc on the january 6th you
see this see these boots brand new boots
see these scuffs right here i don't know
brand new i just they're four days old i
had just
about in texas i went to dc and you know
i scuffed them
thanks to sheila jackson lee from texas
wow
we were in the on the chamber when they
were riding
and so they they get with our gas masks
they said all right everyone getting on
the floor she's like how do you get down
so i got oh my god
and she goes can i can you take a
picture of me she i
she gave me her phone and i took seven
pictures of her
in in action like are you kidding me
within 45 minutes a press release goes
out
representative sheila jackson lee hiding
in the capitol
[ __ ] and people always wonder online
who's taking those pictures
here we go
was it true was it strange that when
they convened
pelosi was not up at the gravel
and she was there when it first first
started right but all of a sudden
uh she was gone and somebody else was
taking her place at the gavel it was
like she disappeared like she
she disappeared well she opened it up
and i was i was above them i heard
her and they kept interrupting her uh
and andy biggs was delivering because
when they when they said hey there's
been a security breach and tear gas
been deployed that's what it got really
real and then they started giving out
they said
underneath you said you have gas masks
no one knew that but underneath
everything
now we know and then they started i'm
like what about us and they started
handing it because we're up in
the gallery handing us the gas pass and
everyone is freaking out
legend is crying and the funny thing is
which is not funny but
you know how afterwards they complain
like uh what's your name
paul from washington yeah yeah yeah
camila
paul yeah they all said
because the republicans are you serious
yes yes let me just tell you
because when we were there there were
six security guards
guns pointing at the door and i was
right behind us listen fools i'm gonna
help you push this door in
right if they break through and i look
back and the only one wearing a mask was
sheila jackson lee
veronica escobar cohen from uh virginia
the the guy who mocked the pledge of
allegiance
oh yeah and then uh of the pledge and
then uh
and then uh val demings from florida
like eight of them and and
uh for milla dia paul none of them was
wearing masks
and they just go down the staircase that
was so cramped down to the basement
and i'm like she's right behind me
because she's in a cave and i'm thinking
no one is our mask
and then we gotta go to gallego's office
because they put us there with
uh congressman gallego from arizona yeah
he's like tarzan he's standing on the
chairs
in the house guys pointing where people
should go i'm like dude you're making a
fool out of yourself
and he's not wearing a mask so he's in
his office drinking scotch with
with uh another member of congress i
love this sorority we're all members
me and all the reporters are masked and
i'm looking at him like it's great that
we're all having to wear masks
you javier i'm not gonna wear a mask in
my office
i'm gonna drink this
drinking his 18 year old scotch
yeah how can how can people reach out to
you on social media
well i'm at a twitter man hob jv and
then m-a-n-j-a-r-r-e-s and
how can people support your campaign
what campaign
[Laughter]
it's coming it's coming ladies and
gentlemen it's gone
it's coming down the road and you'll be
my spokesman and then
the campaign will be over in five days
oh
no you didn't no you didn't
know i'm sorry it's okay you know what
no one listen i'm sorry we go over in
three days
it's okay i'm here we're going to make
it happen
yeah we're going to oh you'll be the
first to know how's that
text me man okay so no thank you man
thank you
for spending the time and i know i knew
you're busy but
uh i appreciate you know see pet seat
back in your backyard
three hour drive man three hour drive
next time they gotta make in miami
because that was like a half hour
i've heard is back in dc it's gonna be
back in dc you know it will contract
well when you've got a contract with
gaylord and he says to do so you've got
to
and that's a fairly new contract right
yeah
this the whole new world we live in
don't mess with the gaylord
did they have a pandemic clause he's got
rights man he's got rice
[Laughter]
is
it's history man that's american history
ladies and gentlemen take a break
teaching the kids some strange history
videos
yeah we're getting ready and when we
come back
we're gonna have more hair from
the 2021
cpac convention here yep in orlando
so again foreign turn off your computer
that was the problem last time i think
she did it again she throwing us under
the bus
remember you're gonna break that's true
story
of paul they were unbelievable no one
was going to ask
you know why
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to
cpap 2021 going to pre-podcast
let me introduce my co-host
the veteran
we're all veterans i know i know all
veterans
the pretty veteran the prettiest yeah
here we go
[Laughter]
that other guy who is
we got some tomorrow uh angel
is not gonna be here but uh not carson
will be here so
we're looking forward so sad i'm gonna
miss that i'm gonna miss that
when he comes he brings clouds
yeah he really does he's literally a
brain surgeon
yeah yeah he bring and we interviewed
him one time
and he came around the corner
it was a bright day it was a bright day
something like this and then all of a
sudden
while we're talking it started to get
dark it's like
what just happened his crowd didn't rain
they blocked the sun
the only other person i've seen do that
is trump yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he had people throw remember he had a
security team like literally throwing
people out of the way
when they were coming down radio row
yeah at that hotel it's really tight
right
at the republican convention one year in
louisiana
uh trump was given one interview
and it was us and when he came in
they looked like bouncers yes huge
large boundaries you can build a wall
out of those guys and
they create a bubble around like
a strategic bubble make a hole make a
hole
they really
okay but um ladies and gentlemen this
cheney
has been angering a lot of conservatives
oh my gosh liz cheating um
and she's using her daddy and uh
her connections 100 establishments yeah
that's why i'm pretty sure
and she doesn't care about your voice
it's easy to see that she doesn't care
about your voice and she'll let you know
that she don't care about your voice
and how she speaks right now we have an
individual that
is running running against her and we're
going to ask him a couple of questions
mr anthony bouchard is running for
congress against liz
cheney and if you have any questions for
him you can text it to us real quick
and we will we will um answer him but
what's up mr burchard
hey glad to be here all right
what's getting you out of wherever you
were to
to take on this chain well look
uh i've been a fighter ever since i got
into politics
this is i'm going in my second term
everybody was against me i mean
the current governor the previous
governor
uh previous secretary of state my county
sheriff
i mean if i was the guy that when they
looked at him they said everybody was
afraid
really and so i'm used to a fight man
i mean i know so and i understand i won
yes i won the fight he's a state senator
by the way
for those of you who aren't familiar
with wyoming politics so uh
i look from the time i got into the
fight the first time
it just seems that you know i win yeah
well the reason we don't win some of
these seats at these higher levels
is because people don't try hard enough
they don't raise enough money
they're afraid to talk bad about their
opponent they want to smile all the time
they want to be the nice guy well even
if you get a nice guy in office
what happens they go to the swamp yep
and they convert them yeah very quickly
there is no more mr smith goes to
washington
there is no more of that why why is
that conversion happening and
why is it so quick is it that they see
that
the glazing glitz or or or
does mitch mcconnell and mccarthy or
whatever the speaker
or or the leaders and then just call
them in the room hey if y'all wanna be
in here y'all gotta raise
five hundred thousand dollars by next
tuesday or something like that
what's going on well there is a study
called the ash
study and i don't know if you've seen
that what they did
was they put people in a room and one
and they're actors okay and then the one
is in there who who's just part of the
experiment
and what they'll do is they'll show like
a different lines
like which one's shorter you know and so
like for instance they're drawn on a
blackboard okay and then the other
person
sits in there and the first time he said
you know who which line is the shortest
line
and the first time he's he picks it
because yeah
you know number four is the shortest
line everybody else says oh it's number
three
and after they do this a few times they
second guess themselves
no they just conform they look around
and go
i'm just gonna spoke with these guys wow
i'm gonna say that
whatever they say i'm gonna say it so
there's a
human nature uh problem here
and you know there's some people that
take that that uh
same study and they'll go in there and
and they'll
you guys are all screwed up they'll get
the heck
let me get the heck out you got some
common sense in there yeah
or you'll get a different reaction yeah
so
they're so my uh uh understanding what's
really happening
it's in their dna either to go along
or it's in their dna to fight it and so
i i know what's in my dna man i've i've
always been
on the other side of the establishment
so look i
i've i've called votes where you're the
only guy standing on the floor
against the establishment and so this
comes back to that ashton
am i going to go along with the herd or
am i i mean
am i going to go opposite i'm going to
fight back i mean
i've caught i've stood up on the floor
and used the rules
right to pull something out of committee
did they kill you imagine that
and actually get a vote on the floor and
and you'll have
most of people vote against you i don't
care right
it's like a bunch of bullies when you
get up there
when you meet the bullies or the ones
that the establishments and what's been
up there forever
when you go up there and you finally
meet them you're one of two people
you're either an appeaser
to appease to get along to go along or
you kind of push back right and then and
then when you do
push back against the bully what does
the bullying actually do automatically
automatically i'm trying to come harder
at you and so a lot of these people
don't have the backbone don't have the
ability don't have the
the wherewithal or the confidence within
themselves i would imagine
i mean you gotta type you have 435
people coming at you
well look i got to tell you back during
my my senate race
and i shouldn't talk about this because
it drags out things that
had happened i i was being attacked by
a fellow senator and
i do it i went back i hit a par
and i'm just going to be real honest
with you today i mean if you look at
you you know there's a time to fight and
there's a time
to also get along right and i don't mean
get along
i mean if you were a legislator
and we butt heads and you endorse
my opponent and we fight
and but then then i win we're gonna
shake hands
and we're gonna try to get things done
right right right and
so so there's a difference there
than the go along get along prep the go
along get along crowd never fights
okay they always get along and so
so i hope that explains there's a
difference in how we
fight we fight when we fight we play
hard
and try to do good policy right
and that means that we're going to
disagree at times
right but if if we're legislators on the
on in a body
but but i will tell you this this is
where it really differs from a state
policy person you know or legislator
to the swamp is that often a state
legislature will get things done that
needs to be done for the people
yeah right and congress tends
i mean let's be honest if it wasn't for
their printing press
right what would we need him for exactly
yeah and so what happened well how else
would we get gender studies to pakistan
right
for the tune of what 200 200 million 200
billion
be m whatever just throw something at it
senator bashar speaking of good policy
uh what sets you apart from liz cheney
what are you going to bring to the table
well i mean as far as what kind of
policy would i push yeah i mean
i mean my policy would be like the
things that she votes
against i mean if it was as little as a
one percent cut she votes against it
you know so forget it when it's when
it's a 15
billion dollar cut we can't get her to
do that either so
i think we need to limit government okay
and that's the biggest problem we have
and it doesn't matter
at the state level too i mean it's so
getting the monster off our back is one
of the huge priorities
are you a second amendment guy what are
you saying you guys don't know me huh
i'm not from wyoming yeah be honest with
you no i'm a sincere kid
i don't know so marilyn here so let's go
back i mean i don't know how long you
guys have here but uh
good just give your your elevator pitch
to the folks listening at home yeah we
want to we want to know
the crux of the matter for you yeah okay
so what happened in 2008
when i saw that it was inevitable we
were gonna
have a federal push to take your gun
rights away
i founded guami gun owners
and uh that's how i kind of got in the
fight i i took two years to build a list
i traveled the state got people to sign
petitions
and uh sign up on my email list i mean
the petitions was just to gather names
yes and i built the biggest list of gun
owners in the state people that wanted
to fight back and by
2010 you can look this up anthony
bouchard
email blitz and there's actually an
article online when i first went into
politics it said i think it's montana
paper still has it up
and uh basically what happened is i
built a
a system online on a
web page where they could email all
members of the committee
wow and i had a bill sponsor pushing a
bill
and man these guys got hammered so bad
they didn't know what was going on i
mean i'm
not like i said i'm just an ordinary guy
but i kind of thought about it i went
how do i move the ball
right somebody got a pen i think i need
to be writing this down
yeah so i i basically what happened is
by 2011
we actually had the best bill in play
because see
look in 2010 it wasn't the bill that i
had really
had anything to do with and it had some
penalties in it
where like for instance alaska if you
uh are stopped by a police officer
whether you're carrying a gun on your
side or we have one in the car
you've got to tell the police officer
and then
it's a high misdemeanor if you don't so
it's bad stuff
it's a fourth amendment violation so
when so there was that language of the
2010 bill and i'll be honest with you we
only pushed so hard
because i wanted that out of that
language and there were people that were
mad at me
because you know you're not pushing this
as hard as you should no because if
you're a routine traffic stop you're
suddenly a felon by just not declaring
when they should really assume all
americans are carrying assume we're all
carrying i'll come back and tell you
story on that
but again fourth amendment right to
search and seizure right
so you're gonna tell on yourself in the
fifth amendment too
the fifth amendment to shut the hell up
in case you all don't know the fifth
amendment means shut the hell up
exactly and so uh so what happened was
uh this this bill we had the right bill
2011. okay and it and by the way it
wasn't
a sexy bill because it didn't have all
the nice words that you wanted a gun
bill
what it was was a technical bill that
just moved all the pieces
to make it happen so people looked at it
went well how does this do that
it's like yeah you're not going to know
because it's it's you know
it's after that comma it tells you
what's happening there
you know what i mean the next i mean
this was just a technical bill so
so anyway we put we put all the heat
behind it and uh
we put it in the weaker house okay
because if we could get it out of the
weaker house we knew
that we could all right it's going to
sail through the other house so anyway a
lot of fun man we had uh
we had postcards that were by this time
we were doing a different program
so we had mail postcards going out to
the entire state where people filled it
out that
i'll be watching how you vote on this
critical issue wow
and then they were sending it into the
legislature i could watch this stuff
being delivered
that's amazing a lot of fun yeah yeah
snail now people don't know the power of
snail mail anymore
so let me tell you i want to come back
to the thing about treating everybody
like arm
there was a there was a police chief
love all
wyoming up in the north part of the
state he comes into the committee
and he says you know if we pass this
bill
our officers are going to have to treat
people
like they're they're all armed
and i just could not wait to get back
and make a comment on this and i and so
you got to imagine here's this is kind
of where
we're it was just so basic i think
there's nobody else in this room
does nobody else think about someone
nothing
okay so i said you know i i really think
as mr chairman uh
i see a real problem here if
if a police officer doesn't treat
everybody like our arms
then this bill that we're gonna pass if
this fixes that problem
then we're gonna save lives here yes and
uh sorry man
and you you realize that it was tongue
and cheek yeah but uh
and look yeah and this was before 2020
yeah well and and yeah this is 2011 and
we got that done and uh
i was the guy that when i walked in the
capitol they would come out
and see me and they'd walk on the other
side
that's when you know you built a good
reputation yeah yeah
so so there anyway does that answer your
question on guns heck yes
tech yeah i also let them know who you
are yeah we need you to be talking to
somebody in the state of indiana because
apparently
uh indiana from everything i've ever
known it's been pretty open pretty
pretty
friendly uh second amendment they've now
passing a bill to uh
open carry is no longer good yeah we've
got some issues coming out india but
anyways
where can people find you where can
people get a hold of you
where can people help website
anthony4wyoming.com the number four
or either way i got both okay
and now you know we're at the
quarter of a million right now is where
we're at and that's good i mean
obviously that's
that's nothing and the big scheme of
things when you're going up against the
chain
but uh i will say that most people
they don't they don't get this much we
see people go up against
these level races and they raise 50 000
and
they wonder why they win so and
the whole country is scratching their
head at the liz cheney nonsense
everybody is wondering you know what
what's going on over there you know your
daddy can only carry you so far
well look how bad it was the other day
she starts
talking about the you know the
republican party isn't the party of
white supremacists
and it's like who said that who's the
one that's saying that stuff
and well my thing is
when you add logs onto the fire
you make or a lot of people start
looking a whole lot more at that fire
and when she said that i was like that's
one of the dumbest things that
i could say because it almost
legitimizes what people have been saying
about the problem so if you
are going to say that you had white
supremacy
in your party then you are
legitimizing what other people are
saying
and i mean you mean like nancy pelosi
right well i mean she's legitimizing
nancy pelosi and they say
she's a drunken stupor so when did you
stop beating your wife
well well hold on we're not we're not
the party of white feeders here
to even dignify that defending a
negative answer
i told a press conference i just want to
say that we can't defend
and we are not a party
of lifebeaters we don't wear wife
feeders
we don't promote white feeders
you can support us but we are not white
beaters
they take that to the bank now what you
heard about my
cousin down the street if you have to
tell
somebody who you are then that ain't who
you are
yeah yeah you're trying to prove a
negative you know and you launch from a
false premise
to try and win over that party the party
of the left is never going to be won
over we need to move forward without
them at this point
right well i think the biggest thing
about what she's doing i mean
look at the thing where she's takes
another attack
at trump right right and even mccarthy
has to walk away
yeah and and so what you've got is she's
got a hold the wheel in the helm
and she's trying to steer it a different
direction right
and everybody else has got a hole that
will and they're they're they're saying
no
and uh it's just amazing that she's got
that far me
i think it's got to be that she's in
north
virginia yeah it can't be i mean she's
got to be her circle of friends
right right i mean it can't this isn't
normal
either she's gone off the rails oh she's
up and
needs to have you know go down to the to
the uh
minute clinic something i mean
she needs to get an examination right
because something's wrong
[Laughter]
a
and it is funny but come on yeah she
either has to get
something checked or well get a such
level level
of celebrity and i think this is the
frustration of the the average american
voter
is we don't send you guys to dc
to to queen yourselves to give
yourselves a crown
and forget we exist and occasionally
give us
a check of our own money back while our
kids are starving we're trying to get
jobs we're trying to get back to normal
and and how tone deaf can they be well
look just on the on the whole mask issue
okay
she was saying wear your mask
she's saying dr fauci's a good guy i've
known him forever
you know and in wyoming i don't know
you guys probably don't realize in
wyoming we're up there
who needs a mask right you know and look
the the senators that were on the floor
with us
we're not wearing masks right right i
mean
because if you talk to any doctor
they're not telling you to wear a mask
and i would rather talk to my doctor
about that
than have some politician getting paid
millions of dollars from foreign
interests to tell me what to do
i'm sorry this is america we're not you
know
for me masks create spread nobody wears
them properly they're all touching their
faces touching everything else that is
true nobody wasn't proper
and just just if you really fear the
disease or if you you are
immunocompromised
you take personal responsibility take
care of yourself but the rest of us
really have to get back to work
and technically you and i should both be
clean-shaven if we're going to properly
put on our ppe
right right no well you got too much i
can
i can clean pseudo for electrolytes
you know we saw the masked nazis running
around yesterday threatening to kick me
out
i'm not but then you saw you saw the
dude you saw the dude with fishnet
across his face that's technically
acceptable
yeah i saw him again today yeah i mean
and that's the thing right it's about
it's about compliance
and the american people have never
really been about compliance
that's not in our heritage well they
have put a lot of people in fear though
haven't they
they have and it's a fair machine it's
all it
let me tell you about something that uh
if you go look on my facebook page
you'll see how out on the edge
i i have been so and it's it's not
because i i believe in wacko science
or anything it's because i believe in
real science yes so in 2017
september of 2017 my daughter was 14
years old
got very ill i mean to where she got
pneumonia
and we started this i mean i remember
telling my wife we're going to take her
the doctor it sounded like she's getting
pneumonia
so when she went in her blood oxygen was
low
and the doctor freaked she said you got
to get her to the emergency room
so then we go to the emergency room and
these people tell us that we overdosed
around thailand
and i'm like these people don't know
what the hell they're talking about
and so we but we do admit her because
she does have
you know pneumonia well our doctor came
in that and it was my wife's doctor came
in to talk
to tell her she couldn't sleep she
couldn't sleep unless she's
checked on her she came and said you
better get out of here
she's going to die if she's daisy whoa
and so
we were on an ambulance ride to
children's hospital in denver
and we were there about
four hours before they came in and said
this is what we want to do
so and let me tell you they put her on a
bipap that's
a it's like it's kind of things you see
on like what you see on
uh where people use them for snoring but
it's a more advanced
well yeah he said it's like it but so a
bipap is a little more
uh it goes advanced it goes in yeah yeah
it goes
it goes up and it's sealed around the
nose it pressurized they put
oxygen and they had her on that in the
first 10 minutes i mean
it was like the doctor said paul the ivs
were starting over
and what happened was when they came
into the room
and this is where it gets very important
people need to understand what's
happening here
they said that we want to give her
something that's unconventional
it's to treat malaria oh no
you're about to say the h hold on yeah
no you didn't rain
you listening here we go here we go this
is what american frontline doctors got
in trouble for
so when uh i actually have a t-shirt
with this symbol on it we go here we go
let's hear it so so this is where i
first learned
what hydroxy porquin does
no you did hcq
so what what is the treatment what it
does and it's a vaccination
what it does is is she had a thing
called a cytokine storm
okay and what happens when she got the
virus
her body didn't know what to do right
it's just it was a foreign virus to the
body
it didn't know how to react so it's an
immunity storm kind of situation that's
exactly what it was okay and that's what
they said they said
cause i said what are we gonna give her
something for malaria and she and they
said
that she has a storm that's going after
her body
attacking it and it's going after her
lungs yeah and we have to stop it
and they said that she has a uh sepsis
starting to develop she said she can't
expel the air
right right and and then the cytokines
form everything that's happening is
causing sepsis
so they gave her zpac for that okay and
then they further gave her a steroid
and i gotta tell you we're out of icu in
four days wow yeah
man why don't i have my teeth so i made
this shirt
hcq and i wear it all the time because
they had banned it in some states and
some scenes they actually banned it you
couldn't
you couldn't prescribe it before it got
banned i went off i went on the googles
and i actually purchased uh something
similar to that
that uh core seed and it's uh it's over
the counter hcq but coursing which
helps to open up the lungs and the
airways it
reduces inflammation along so that your
body can heal itself yeah and they were
saying that the reason why africa had
such low covet issues is because of the
anti-malarials that they had
oh no you know actually what i did
that's phenomenal
i was in we were at the children's
hospital for
eight days and i had my laptop with me
and every time these guys would even say
boo i was over there googling
and seeing what was going on of course
that you know we're past google we don't
use that anymore
yeah but uh
look some of it was way over my head i'm
not a i'm not a doctor i'm a
just an ordinary guy right but let me
tell you
what i found back then was that the
reason they knew this worked
was because the 2003 sars is when they
learned that
people would bypass the storm and so
this is
it to me when when and you know what
happened
trump said that word oh no and now it's
safe
and then they uh then it's you're a
conspiracy theorist if you believe in it
we need a mass-produced vaccine whipped
up in nine months
so look i'll tell you another story i
should without without
all right so where can people find you
on social media uh
us on facebook it's uh senator anthony
bouchard
okay and on twitter it's uh anthony
bouchard for congress against liz cheney
okay and there i'm i'm on the other
stuff too i just don't have it in front
of me
sure sure yeah we're all we're all
expanding
gab and parlor and that rumble
all right sir we wish you the best of
luck anthony bouchard running against
liz cheney
hey thanks a lot thank you sir all right
we'll be talking to you
this is great this is great we've had a
lot of a lot of great folks stepping up
and doing
doing the hard work all right so
yes this is this is good no
no no no no we're taking care of her
tomorrow oh okay she's on tomorrow yeah
good thank you
you're welcome you're right i'm just on
top of things looking around
we only have we only have like 10
minutes left and i was like well
and here's the thing too back when i
used to work on political campaigns and
when i was a consultant
i i used to tell the candidate 10
minutes only
you only speak for 10 minutes get
yourself done
you don't tell any mom any like daddy
stories you know
and i'm not knocking hate these
red-blooded americans that are throwing
their hat in the ring
please keep keep them coming keep them
coming but
you guys that are working on political
campaigns learn
learn how to teach your elevator pitch
to these guys
okay that we want to know about policy
we want to know where they stand
they have to drop the fun lace
fundraising link first
very first fundraising first we
shouldn't have to prompt him
and i'm not saying him this guy but
anybody anybody you want to throw in the
seat
they better be ready with that stuff
because i'm learning seriously i'm
learning this too
yeah i'm cutting my teeth running for
city council yep
i'm learning yep now here's kevin sorbo
angel
yes sir angel is a great person
to learn about those things because
angel's been in that before
yep yeah and what's funny is as i got
tired of working in politics
i had to take a break so when donald
trump was sworn in as commander-in-chief
i decided to enlist in the united states
air force
cut my teeth by learning what veterans
experience
i want to make sure that i understand
the military experience as well
um but now i'm back and i'm i'm ready to
help people fight
the boys right now are trying to to flag
down kevin
get up there get up there and uh get
your national file dude too
no yeah there is there he is
is that no no i don't think yeah no
fisher
no official right from national file
kevin sorbo ladies and gentlemen
consorbo two minutes two minutes hi
two minutes with kevin sorbo there we go
well i i'm gonna have to say i normally
don't get star struck
i really don't because i've been in
hollywood i've been in politics for a
long long time
but my daughters uh we've got pure flips
my daughters absolutely love you and i
just want to say
thank you for being i know you've got to
bring up guys but i'll tell you my first
beer flips move is called what if and
it's a better movie than god's not dead
no no that's it same writers daddy so
it's not a you know pure flicks doesn't
mind i say it because i told him i said
dude i
and the writers that did guys on dead
who wrote what up said we feel the same
way
they just didn't do a smart way of
promoting it wow it's not
here's the thing it's tough to promote
independent movies because we don't have
you look at the avengers that's a 100
million dollar publicity budget on a 300
million dollar movie
with that right so we need to word them
out right now you're talking about the
movie at the very end of the movie your
character
that's trailers i got hit by a car and
died that's right your character do it
no no no no two million dollar movie
made 140 million dollars
who made more money for pure flicks all
their movies combined
wow they're now sort of on the outs a
little bit they sold their streaming
service to sony firm rich peluso's
company
and i don't know what's going to happen
with their everything else they got
going on anyway
i saw that movie first before assault
god's not dead so i was already i was
awesome you guys are already like this
you guys like this yeah
i am so glad we follow each other
because i love to hear
what you have to say on social media
especially with faith
faith and and the way and the way that
you approach here
uh now one of the questions i have for
you is
what motivates you to stand
up the way that you're doing because a
whole lot of people getting attacked a
whole lot of people are getting
cancelled do you know facebook took me
down two weeks ago
facebook took away my page 550 000
followers they took away without telling
me why
wow i'll tell you why i know why we all
know why
it's just being a conservative being a
christian it's like double leper and
they just they want to get rid of me i
posted nothing but the truth but you
can't do the truth anymore because
they love they love the lie and uh where
does they keep battling
so what what what your question was what
made me want to do it what
what motivated you or what motivates you
to keep doing this even though you're
getting attacked
you're getting brought down you're
getting easy the hypocrisy
i get tired of that i do as i say but
not as i do sort of mentality
and uh i just got to a point being on
sets of television movies and hear
people say stuff i go
well where do you get that where does
that come from and they never have a
good answer
right because right now we live in a
world where the left all they want to do
is attack you with with labels
right you're racist you're a homophobe
you're you're a you know you're a nazi
all this kind of stuff
they go how am i nazi they don't have
reasons why
you know like antifa really they're
against fashion they are the fascists
but it's all about projection it's all
we're putting the other way yeah
how do we let these people go through
our cities and and beat up people with
baseball bats and tires and destroy
people's businesses
and do nothing about it right i just got
to a point look
my agent manager about 10 years ago said
we can't get any more work
because of what because where you stand
politically and i said wait a minute
you guys are the industry that
constantly screams for tolerance
and freedom of speech but it's a one-way
street for both those things
so thank god i still have a a job in the
industry that i love
because i don't know i've got atheist
friends diagnostic friends i've got
christian friends i've got
liberal friends and we we kind of laugh
at the whole thing that's going on with
the hate and anger out there
because it's absolutely ridiculous so i
decided i want to keep doing movies that
have a positive message
yeah i have three new movies coming up
this year one director called miracle in
east texas
we got lou gossip there with me we got
john ratzenberger we got tyler mayne
who's a wwf guy but a lot of kids know
him as
as sabretooth and all the extra movies
but it's a true story set in 1930
it's won all kinds of awards it's going
to be in um
theaters of spring i've got another one
called one nation under god it's a high
school drama dealing with putting that
phrase back under a pledge of allegiance
another movie a girl who believed in
miracles i started with mira sorvino and
peter coyote
and it's a wonderful little movie about
this little girl who's got
who's got cancer that has these visions
and has these things that come true and
it's very touching
emotional story i'm here doing climate
hustle two it's my new documentary
climatehustle2.com please go on there
we're going to screen it tomorrow plus
i'm doing a q a on it
tomorrow at four o'clock here at cpac
and it deals with the other side of the
global warming issue
i call it weather okay
i don't know if we're gonna keep us
living in fear mr producer
i think we're good we're clear well you
know what there's a graph that came out
that's fine
this guy put together climate hustle two
the number two
when they go to the site dot dot com
there's a graph that came out for the
last 100 years
of the average temperatures around the
world it's not just like in
one place around the world you know how
warm it's got in the last hundred years
0.41 degrees less than a half of a
degree
we're on our hotter years yes have there
been colder years but let's spend
trillions of dollars and teach
kindergarten kids
to fear how bad man is destroying the
earth
even though antarctica has more ice now
than it said 20 years ago
and the polar bears are doing just fine
dude what food can we raise
if the temperature does go up a little
bit i mean back when i was in school
they taught us that the earth ebbed and
flowed out of ice ages
so how are we suddenly we can never have
any change in climate ever again
if we do
it's all about fear and control fear is
an amazing weapon
fauci came out a year ago in march he
came out and said oh you don't pour mass
you can look it up
don't say that man we want we want to
keep people living in fear
and use this as a weapon to control
people's lives yes because your mom and
pap grocery store ain't essential but
costco on target
and your local grocers are there it's
they're essential and liquor stores i'm
not i'm not
super close i love picking and choosing
home depot and letters
it's crazy what we've done around the
world to destroy so many people's lives
and businesses
you know what we were talking about that
earlier today with um
on the panel where the government has
uh destroyed a whole lot of these
mom-and-pop shops
but then you got an achievement going in
there and finishing by burning
murdering them up yeah and destroying
them up at the same time and
i mean look and we do nothing we don't
we don't support anarchy or anything
like that
but sooner or later you have to realize
the american people ain't going to take
all this stuff anymore
and they're going to start fighting back
and by the way right now
exactly it's starting to happen
questioning and
choosing to make decisions for your own
health is not anarchy
it is not extremism i mean what clown
world are we living in mr sorbo
are there any more like you in hollywood
are you the only jew in babylon
there are more but i'm telling you right
now
apathy is the biggest killer of the
right right now yeah we go oh my god the
hollywood they you know the left they
own music the television the movies
what can we do 95 percent of the media
is on the left
well they're on that because we need to
be as passionate as him without being as
angry and hateful and divisive as him
but we have to
be as passive and people need to start
doing stuff trust me i hate the fact
that hollywood has kicked me out of
their club but
i was never a hollywood guy to begin
with i grew up in a small town of
minnesota
i grew up with proper values trust me
yes but uh i love the industry
i love the business and thank god i can
still keep working and do movies
i'm doing the next left behind movie
we're starting that soon i'll be
directing that one as well wow i got a
movie with antonio sabato and his
company
and we're doing this called the
trailblazers
it's a western but trailblazers has more
than just one meaning in it
and uh it's going to be a lot of
conservative actors putting this movie
together
and um i've got the number one um
documentary on on amazon right now
called before the wrath that's an
educational look at the book of
revelation in the bible it's pretty
fascinating
and trust me the bible will scale the
hell out of you
yes no antonio sabato known for a long
time great great guy um
pure flicks you guys if you don't have
it you have to have it there's a lot of
regular shows on there
there are great shows to watch with your
kids yeah you're not embarrassed
with your kids and you will be shocked
as i was
the actors that are on there uh one of
my heroes have you met
or been around lee majors yes i know
very well
bro i've done a lot of autograph shows
with him
i was i said i said kids
[Laughter]
don't get it wrong man don't get it
right he's married to farrah fawcett i
had like when i was in high school i had
her poster
and people know me i do not i never i
don't know anybody that's ever seen me
get starstruck but i'm telling you
lee majors and here's here's what i
don't know
because of my kids and because of my
wife i never would have your kids
12 11 and the boy is six and a half
goals okay the sixth and after i do two
movies with lionsgate believe me believe
it or not there are some g-rated movies
out there
and lighted two with lions gate shot
right here in florida bernie the dolphin
one
bernie the dolphin two break the kids
out of the age of ten they would love it
they would love it
i played as a goofy bad guy i had a lot
of fun with it
had a lot of fun thank god thank god for
folks like you kevin sorbo because
you really represent americans i mean
americans look at hollywood and we're
like what happened
i'll tell you what after hercules i did
a series called andromeda it was the
first show gene roddenberry created
after star trek that's captain dylan
hunt
first half after captain kirk okay so i
had 12 straight years of those two shows
i get stopped all the time now not
because of either those shows
because of god's not dead what if let
there be light that's where people stop
me
80 of time now at airports hotel lobbies
they please make more movies like that
there's 80 million households in america
that want family friendly movies and
hollywood
is ignoring it because of their ideology
it's ridiculous it's called show
business not show show
make movies that families want to see
and you can laugh all the way to the
bank
about our stupid christians and
conservatives
let everybody know uh um real quick
about that website that you
uh just put up
serbofamilyfilmstudios.com
is my production company please go there
sign up
donate we'll raise money for our next
movie um starboardfamilyfilmsnews.com
and also kevincircle.net you can go
there
but the movie is climatehustle2.com
okay and uh you you've been kicked off
facebook so where can people find you
now i'm on twitter i'm still on twitter
but also go to cloudhub
now they're here now i'm going to be
speaking with them later as well okay
cloudhub is awesome
and i got to give one more of them it's
a different sort of app
free space go to free space it is
incredible after that there we go
kevin serving ladies and gentlemen thank
you for your time sir i really
appreciate it god bless thank you so
much
thank you so much you got a fanboy over
here
hollywood has to show you how to take
the photo
[Laughter]
yeah the lighting is weird here yep
three come rollerblading by me look on
the other side of me they said how do
you want to make an order
oh my god that's amazing thank you so
much god bless you guys
thank you so much that's amazing yeah
that's great
yes
and she's got a book coming out so we're
going to be we're going to be chatting
with her tomorrow
well you guys will be i'm i'm i'm going
to be out of town right here
so that's a great thing about cpac is i
mean everybody just comes and
you never know you never know who's
going to show you and
we're all in the same fight we're all in
the same fight
um and that's that's what i love about
this especially radio road radio bro you
get everybody walking by
so um but yeah just
just great stuff i mean pure flicks
papa papa doesn't know where his camera
is thank you so much here i'll hold it
up for mine
i'll hold up for mine
here we go words for warriors
sam sorbo kevin sorbo's wife amazing
book she'll be in to talk about it
tomorrow thank you
we know how important wives are yeah we
got we got uh props on the book from
sean spicer monica crowley
eric with texas mike lindell ted nugent
and david webb so she's killing it
yeah fight back against crazy socialism
and then never mind sick liberal
you never know what's going to happen
you never ever know don't show up
and fanboy johnny uh was able to
oh my gosh trying just turned into like
school yeah i'm so sorry
my kids are going to lose mushy
i don't normally geek out license but
oh my gosh
we've been binging on this pure flicks
recently because
yeah i mean that's something we turn on
some of these movies i'm like
one of these movies had jackie chan in
it i had to turn the damn thing off
yeah it was that bad yeah even the stuff
they put on like
the kids channels these days i get yeah
i get uncomfortable i have a i have a 13
year old niece and there
sometimes i i can't watch tv with her
even like on the kids channels like this
is i can't believe what they're putting
on tv these days and
labeling it for children i'm still not
over uh spongebob
that's my boy you spongebob that's my
boy
they got uh hidden messages in the
background but no no
hallmark hallmark of the family channel
one of the two is when we finally cut
the cable
they said the upcoming show for this
evening don't miss
and it showed a dad transitioning the
family crying
and crying him getting dressed he had a
transition there was transitioning
and the son who was like 10 years old
hugging him saying it's okay daddy
we support you and i'm like oh hell no
this is the last straw my kids
family channel yeah homework channel
we playing this game yeah no that's um
that reminds me of uh mike cernovich's
documentary that was on amazon prime
called hoaxed
and also guys amazon let that stay up
there as long as they did because he
called
he called bezos out um but uh he
actually talks about that that you know
it's
they call it programming for a reason
right tv show
programming for a reason you can't leave
your kids unattended in front of a tv
anymore i know you can't and like god
forbid they might have a tablet in their
room what are they watching
i mean so and it's unfortunate and like
i said my
kids uh 13 11 and 6 and
we are not we cannot they want to be on
the youtube watch the videos
that's going to pop up i can't let them
go down the road of that because all of
a sudden
i come back and a half hour later and
what they were watching five minute
crafts is now turned into some kind of
sexual deviation
uh-huh you son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah i
could watch a youtube i could watch a
youtube video on how to change like the
headlight on my jeep and suddenly
you go down the rabbit hole and you know
the world trade towers were an inside
job like
it escalates quickly what got me was
netflix
uh usually they waited until season two
to have two guys kissing
uh and now it's the second episode of
season one
they're right into it i'm like wait a
minute
i i can't say that yeah i cancelled
netflix after cuties
cuties was the final straw for me it
really was
we gotta start we have to start
boycotting back
boycotting back because this is but when
you
say that we have individual see i don't
even like
uh uh uh showing stuff on
youtube right right we don't
but when we tell people okay we're not
gonna broadcast on youtube anymore
we're gonna go to other platforms
they will say yay and then they'll go
find somebody else to watch on youtube
they won't leave youtube
yeah they won't leave even though we
leave they won't leave
no it's like wait a minute we're doing
it
out together yeah who's coming with me
yeah and then
and then i'm holding the goldfish i know
all right we are getting ready to roll
for the evening yep
and i wanted to thank angel
thank you angel thank you sir uh being
with us these two days
it was an honor to be here with you guys
awesome i wish i could have been here
for the whole weekend but she um
she was with us five years ago and she's
back now and
uh whatever decision that you make
yeah i'm in the corner on that one heck
yeah heck yeah
yeah i'd love to collaborate with you in
the future absolutely we gotta dust off
the old
the whole team get that get that channel
going all together
we used to have some fun back in the day
yeah
yep that was back when you were still on
news ninja now look at you
yeah somebody said you two brought up to
me
i think that was me no man now you can
never be too grumpy i asked if you're
gonna show up in pajamas i think like
no no we gotta stay cool i wanna thank
brian
brian uh for being here bryant brown's
gonna be here tomorrow
and we're gonna make do some
some more interviews and stuff like that
so we hope that you tune in
and my name is wayne dupree and i am the
host of the wayne dupris
podcast show whatever you want to call
it but uh
i don't know what y'all going to do for
the rest of the day
but y'all get y'all got to get the heck
out of here yeah you don't have to go
home
you